[Música]
เฮ
Olá, minhas amigas, meus amigos. Sejam
muito bem-vindos para mais uma live da
nossa comunidade do
YouTube. Por favor, medida que vocês vão
entrando, vão me dando o feedback do
som, se o som tá adequado, se vocês me
ouvem bem. Hoje eu tô sem o
microfone habitual, mas eu creio que vai
ficar bom o áudio. Boa noite, Alice
Vogel. Me dá a informação, por
gentileza, se o som tá legal. Tá
ótimo. Obrigado pelo feedback. Bem,
vamos às
perguntas. Primeira pergunta aí na tela.
Existe um suplemento que possa ajudar no
uso das estatinas, aliás, para evitar o
uso das estatinas. No meu caso, placa
nascidas tem os 70 anos, tem vários
suplementos que podem ajudar, tá? Eu vou
falar só de alguns deles, os principais
que eu
uso. O que que você deve evitar estatina
ou utilizar estatina em baixa dosagem,
apesar de ser um medicamento muito
comumente prescrito para reduzir o
herdério colesterol, que entre aspas é o
colesterol ruim. E de fato ele tem um
papel para desacelerar o acúmulo de
placa nas artérias, porém ele tem vários
efeitos colaterais, entre eles aumento
do risco de demência, aumento do risco
de diabetes e também problemas
mitocondriais. Ele baixa sua energia
para as células poderem processar os
nutrientes. O que eu mais gosto de usar
no consultório é uma combinação de
berberina. A beberina é extraída de
várias plantas. São quatro plantas que
têm beberina. A mais conhecida é o
bérberes vulgares. Ele reduz o ed
colesterol em até 25 pontos e também
reduz os triglices que são
importantes. E a gente associa muito a
beberina também ao exanicotinato de
noositol que é uma forma da niaacina que
também aumenta o HDL colesterol e baixa
também o LDL colesterol. Tem também um
extrato do arroz vermelho, né, o Red
East Rice, também conhecido como
monascos purpúrios. Ele tem uma eficácia
similar às estatinas. A dose geralmente
vai de 600 mg duas a três vezes ao
dia. Eu não falei o ecotinato geralmente
de 500 mg a 1 g duas vezes ao dia. A
beberina é de 500 mg duas a três vezes
ao dia. Ômega-3 ajuda
bastante. A dose são 3 g ao dia. A
cúrcuma não tem um efeito muito potente
para baixar o LDL colesterol, mas pode
ajudar principalmente pelo efeito
antiinflamatório. A vitamina K2 ajuda a
evitar o acúmulo de cálcio na parede das
artérias. É bem interessante também para
ajudar nesses casos. A coenzima Q10, ela
pode ser utilizada como uma substância
que vai contrabalançar o efeito
colateral das estatinas e ela também tem
um efeito interessante aumentar a
energia celular, tá? E tem também os
tocotrienois, que é uma classe de
vitamina E. Tem o alfa tocoferol, o beta
tocoferol e o delta tocoferol e o gama
tocoferol. São quatro
diferentes, desculpa, tocotrienol, tá?
São quatro tocotrienóis e quatro
tocoferoidis, mas aqui pro pra questão
de colesterol, os tocotrienois são mais
potentes, né? Especialmente o gama e o
delta tocotrienol.
E a alimentação tem que ser rica em
fibras para ajudar, né, a controlar
essas gorduras e criar
antioxidantes e gorduras saudáveis como
gordura do abacate, do azeite de oliva,
das
castanhas.
OK? Tem também a o extrato de alho, é um
ótimo suplemento, especialmente o alho
envelhecido e o alho negro.
E tem
também os fitoesteroides, também ajuda a
controlar o colesterol, tá? A próxima
pergunta, testes de intolerância
alimentar são confiáveis? Vá
investimento? Isso é uma ótima pergunta,
tá? Essa é uma ótima
pergunta. Depende muito, tá? O que que
eu faço, Relita?
Pessoas que
têm hábitos alimentares muito ruins não
devem fazer esse exame de intolerância,
que é o geralmente o que vê IGG, né,
imunoglobulina da classe G, porque eh o
exame vai sair muito poluído,
tá? O exame vai sair muito poluído. O
que quer dizer isso? O glúten, o açúcar,
os agrotóxicos.
várias substâncias ambientais vão abrir
a barreira intestinal e isso vai trazer
uma poluição nesse exame que vai dar
reativo a muitos alimentos diferentes.
Então, antes de pedir esse exame, eu
sempre dou uma limpada na alimentação,
tirando os processados, refinados,
industrializados, o
açúcar, agrotóxico, glúten, caseína.
Porque se você faz esse exame assim sem
limpar a dieta, eh, ele vai vir muito
alterado, tá? E no Lemos Laboratório,
eles têm um cuidado especial que é o
seguinte, quando o IGG dá positivo, tem
quatro classes de IG, tá?
Eh, eles verificam, eles fazem uma prova
cruzada com IGE para realmente ver se
essa intolerância alimentar ela é
significativa. Então, se você perguntar
para um gastro ortodoxo, ele vai dizer
para você que esses exames não tm
comprovação científica e não dá para
validar a eficácia. Por que que eles
falam isso? Porque geralmente o exame
pedido sem limpar a dieta primeiro, né?
Ele vai realmente dar um resultado que
vai ser pouco
útil, certo?
Então, eh, eu sugiro que faça no Lemos
depois de fazer uma limpeza na dieta,
porque no Lemos eles têm esse cuidado de
fazer provas cruzadas para ver realmente
quais são as intolerâncias alimentares
significativas.
Mas se você não quiser investir nesse
exame de
intolerância, tem um jeito de fazer
também mais trabalhoso, mas que você não
vai gastar dinheiro com exame, que é a
dieta de eliminação. Você retira a
maioria dos alimentos suspeitos e vai
reintroduzindo um por um a cada três
dias. Então você fica de quatro a seis
semanas sem comer o alimento e depois
você vai reintroduzindo um por um para
ver qual deles vai te dar reação,
tá? Na real, esses testes de
intolerância por IGG, eles não vão ser
adequados para boa parte dos casos. Boa
parte dos casos não vão valer o
investimento se você não limpou a dieta
antes. Então, na dúvida, não faça esse
exame, especialmente se você não tiver
orientação
médica. Próxima pergunta da
[Música]
Marilda. Spray nasal de própolis ou
spray nasal de prata coleidal pode
ajudar no ressecamento das vias
respiratórias pelo efeito do ar raro
efeito em altitudes?
Marilda ainda tá no Mati Pito, né? Tem
tem um mês que ela está no Mati Pito,
pelo jeito, né? Tô brincando,
Marilda. Então, eh, o spray de própolis
e o de prata coidal vão ajudar sim no
alívio do
ressecamento das respiratórias.
São mecanismos de ação diferentes.
Própolis, que é produzido pelas abelhas,
vai ter propriedade antiinflamatória,
antimicrobiana, vai ajudar a hidratar a
mucosa nasal, vai ajudar a reduzir
secreções, vai ajudar a reduzir
irritações, vai prevenir
infecções, que é comum em áre se rar
efeitos, né? A prata coloroidal também
vai ter esse efeito antimicrobiano, vai
ajudar na eliminação de microrganismos,
na hidratação também.
Em altitudes elevadas, onde o ar tá com
menos oxigênio e a pressão atmosférica é
mais baixa, o organismo tende a acelerar
a respiração. Isso vai ressecar as
mucosas e aumentar o risco de pegar uma
infecção. Então, os sprays que você
comentou podem complementar a hidratação
tradicional com soro
fisiológico. Então você deve associá-los
a outras práticas como tá bem hidratada,
usar o medidificador, se for possível,
evitar a exposição prolongada ao frio
intenso. O própolis tem flavonoides que
sem ação antiinflamatória e ação
antioxidativa que pode ser causada pelas
condições extremas de
altitude. OK? Apesar dos benefícios dos
dois produtos do própolis e da prata
coleid, não substitua medidas essenciais
como aclimatação gradual, monitoramento
de sintomas de mal-estar por altitude,
ok? E você também use antes eh soluções
salinas tradicionais e depois é que você
pode utilizar o spray de própolis ou
prata coloidal.
Próxima pergunta, Fernando. Doutor, o
exame de LDL oxidado poderia ser
utilizado para ajustar suplementos
antioxidantes, por exemplo, aumentar a
vitamina E ou alfa lipoico?
Sim, na verdade oxidado, você pode fazer
sim e uso desse exame. Eu
particularmente tenho preferido pedir a
relação a polipoproteína B e a a
polipoproteína A1, porque os planos
cobrem, o LDL é oxidado é um exame que
os planos não cobrem.
Existe um pouco de controvérsia em
relação a esse exame do LDL oxidado,
porque a maioria dos lugares vê, na
verdade não é ele diretamente, mas os
anticorpos contra o LDL oxidado. Então
existe um pouco de controvérsia se vale
a pena não pedir esse exame com essa
técnica indireta de ver o
anticorpo. Mas esse exame pode ajudar a
orientar o uso de substâncias
antioxidantes. Se tiver aumentado a
oxidação do LDL, convém você usar
tocotrieno da família da vitamina E.
Convém você usar o o ácido
alfalipólico também
nac. Você pode complementar esse exame
também com gluta peroxidase e gluta
transferase no
sangue. Mas é muito importante também
você otimizar a dieta, né? Cortando os
alimentos inflamatórios e colocando os
alimentos ricos e antioxidantes, né?
como são as castanhas,
nozes, eh, macadâmia, amêndoas, sementes
como semente de girassol, semente de
abóbora, os vegetais
coloridos, combater fatores
prooxidantes, como é o caso de estresse,
tabagismo, excesso de
açúcar e usar os suplementos que eu já
comentei. OK?
Então você pode fazer exame de edéico
oxidado, mas eu faria primeiro o exame
de apoipoproteína um, apipoproteína B
antes de fazer o edélio oxidado.
OK? Ao iniciar uso de creatina, o senhor
eu recomenda fazer a saturação no
músculo tomando 5 g quatro vezes ao dia
por 7 dias? Eu geralmente eu não faço
assim comigo mesmo, tá? Eh, não que tá
errado fazer, mas eh eu acho que é um
pouco de preciosismo isso. Se você
quiser ter resultados mais rápidos, pode
fazer isso sim, tá? E como relação a
tomar com água ou suco pode ser de
qualquer
tipo, não vejo problema nenhum, mas
geralmente eu misturo com ei protein e
água, tá? Ou outra proteína como
colágeno. Frutas cítricas, por exemplo,
podem influenciar na absorção?
Tá, antes de responder isso das frutas
cítricas, eu queria esclarecer que essa
estratégia de tomar 20 g por dia por 5 a
7 dias para saturar e depois passar
paraa dose de manutenção, ela pode
acelerar o preenchimento dos estoques
musculares, mas muitas pessoas têm
desconforto gastrointestinal com doses
acima de 10 g,
tá? Então, fica atento quanto a isso,
que tem gente que tem náusea, tem gases,
tem tontura, tá? Então, a saturação pode
ser eh ruim para algumas pessoas, tem
que ter cautela nisso daí, tá? E a
creatina pode ser misturada com qualquer
líquido, seja água, seja suco,
seja vida isotônica, né? Existe um mito
de que as frutas ácidas prejudicariam a
absorção da creatina, mas não existe
isso, tá? O suco de laranja ou limão não
interfere. O ácido estomacal é muito
mais potente que essas frutas, então não
teria sentido elas afetar a creatina,
OK?
sucuzicos e em alguns carboidratos
simples, apesar de eu não recomendar
isso para pessoas que têm resistência
insulínica, podem potencializar
absorção, estimular a insulina. Então,
poderia ajudar em pessoas que não têm
resistência insulínica o transporte de
creatina pros músculos, ok?
Mas não tomem refrigerantes ou bebidas
muito
açucaradas, porque obviamente são
nutricionalmente
desfavoráveis. E para otimizar os
resultados, mantém a suplementação
diária, inclusive com fontes naturais de
nutrientes, como carnes vermelhas,
associado a vegetal rico e vitamina C
para
melhorar a absorção de outros compostos,
OK? Hidratação é muito importante, sono
é muito importante, atividade física, é
gerenciamento do
estresse. Próxima pergunta, Thaago.
Comprei um creme de demenció com aloe
vera. Há algum problema de fazer uso
contínuo passar junto com óleo de
castor? Óleo de castor a gente chama de
óleo de ríel no Brasil, tá? Eh, Estados
Unidos eles chamam de castor oil, mas no
Brasil a gente chama de oscóleo de
riscidon, tá?
Então, passar junto com óleo de eh de
río teria algum efeito benéfico extra?
Por exemplo, prevenir a queimadura da
pele pelo
DMSO ou potencializar o efeito do óleo
de rice no tratamento de
artrite? Sim. Eh, essa associação de MSO
com aloe
vera é uma boa associação, tá? Só que o
uso contínuo tem que ter cautela, porque
a aloe vera, apesar de ela ajudar a
hidratar e proteger a pele, se você
errar na concentração do MSO, se você
usar ele em concentrações altas ou se
você utilizar por um período muito
longo, é possível ter ressecamento, é
possível irritação e sensibilidade. Tem
que fazer os testes, tá? Especialmente
pessoas mais sensíveis.
Então você inicia com aplicações uma,
duas vezes ao dia para sentir como é que
vai ser a tolerância da pele, tá? O óleo
de rícino, né, que é o que você chamou
de castor ou castro oil, pode sim ajudar
também no DMSO. Ele tem o o ácido
ricinoleico que tem ação
antiinflamatória, que é comprovada para
livre de dores articulares. Você pode
aplicar pós absorção completa do DMSO
que dura uns 20 a 30 minutos.
Isso pode potencializar os efeitos
terapêuticos, além de prevenir o
ressecamento da pele, que é causado pelo
demento, né? Então, porém, no caso do
óleo de rís, não evite misturar ele os
dois produtos, né? O DMO, o óleo de
rícino de forma direta na pele, porque o
Demenciol pode aumentar a absorção de
componentes do óleo de rícino, que em
geral é seguro, mas pode acontecer
reações individuais. Então, você faz em
sequência, tá? Você faz
o primeiro o DMSO e depois o óleo de
rícil. É importante que você sempre
limpe a pele antes de aplicar o DMSO
para evitar a absorção de impurezas e
ofte por produtos com demencial em
concentrações de
25%, tá? para não ter muita irritação na
pele. Na live passada, na
pergunta sobre tratamento de osteoporose
de forma integrativa, o senhor
recomendou ou mencionou sobre ser um
tratamento longo. Sim, é longo, podendo
levar de três ou mais anos, dependendo
do caso e da pessoa para ver a
diferença. Isso contando com o uso de
anabolizante ou anabolizante ajuda a
acelerar o tratamento? Bem, eu falei de
modo geral,
tá? E logicamente que a o anabolizante
ele vai acelerar o processo sim, mas tem
que ser tomado muito cuidado no uso do
anabolizante, né? não pode ser utilizado
por mais de seis semanas
não. E a gente indica o anolizante
especialmente para pessoas que já têm
sarcopenia acentuada e pessoas que têm
risco alto de fratura.
Então, cada caso tem que ser analisado.
Se a pessoa
tiver um risco muito aumentado
cardiovascular, eu não recomendaria
utilizar esses anabolizantes para
aumentar a densidade óssea, mas
geralmente quando eu uso, eu uso com
muito cuidado, muito critério e os
resultados são muito bons, tá? É só você
não exagerar no tempo. Nunca me
arrependi de usar quando eu selecionei
bem os pacientes para esse tipo de
tratamento.
Próxima pergunta
aqui. É comum pessoas serem intolerantes
ou não poderia consumir óleo de coco por
algum motivo?
Apenas uso óleo de coco e azeite de
oliva para cozinhar. Eu sofro de alguns
problemas digestivos devido a outras
causas, mas notei, por exemplo, que se
faz pipoca no óleo de coco para ser mais
saudável. So mau estado depois de comer,
o que não cito como até mesmo pipocas
não saudáveis, como a de microondas. Eu
gostaria de saber se tem algum tipo de
pessoa ou
condição que o óleo de coco pode fazer
mal. Sim, tem gente que tem intolerância
ao óleo de coco. Geralmente ele é bem
tolerado, mas tem pessoas que têm
sensibilidade ou contradicação pro
consumo. Então ele tem ácidos grásos
saturados, a maioria de cadeia média,
né, 56%.
Mas se você consumir em excesso pode
causar gases de conforto abdominal,
inchaço, mesmo
diarreia se o seu pâncreas não conseguir
produzir, né, lipaz suficiente para
quebrar essa
gordura. Isso é especialmente comum em
pessoas que têm sistema digestório
sensível ou que já tá com uma disbiose
com deficiência de elastase pancreática.
Então, malestar vai est relacionado a
fatores como quantidade
ingerida, como é que você aqueceu também
esse óleo de
coco ou se você tem uma sensibilidade
específica a esse produto. Se você
sentiu isso, então você é melhor evitar
de usar o óleo de coco para pipoca.
errado ter alergia o coco, mas ela
existe, né? Algumas pessoas têm reação
alérgica às proteínas residuais que
estão nesse óleo de um
pouco. Pessoas que têm a o intestino
irritável do tipo de arrico, né, pode
ter problema com óleo de coco também,
porque ele pode acelerar o trânsito
intestinal.
O ideal é você aumentar aos pouquinhos o
consumo, começar com quantidades
pequenas, avaliar a
tolerância e também combinar com outras
gorduras, intercalar com azeite de oliva
extravirgem para equilibrar esse perfil
lipídico. Vamos ver mais perguntas
aqui. Próxima pergunta aqui. Você pode
falar um pouco a respeito das causas e
tratamento de
furúnculo? Antes deixa eu ver se tem
mais alguma pergunta nova
aqui. Não, não tem
não. Bem, o que que é furúnculo? é uma
infecção profunda na raiz do
pelo. Geralmente é provocado por uma
bactéria estafilococosaureus. Ela vive
naturalmente na pele, mas se acontece
uma lesão, algum
machucado, como arranhão, picada de
inseto ou até atrito, a bactéria pode
penetrar pra raiz do pelo e infeccionar,
tá? são os fatores que vão facilitar
essa infecção? Sistema imunológico
comprometido, enfraquecido, diabetes,
obesidade higiene inadequada, tudo isso
aumenta o risco. Então, a infecção forma
um caroço vermelho, que também é
doloroso e forma pus, né? Como em áreas
como axila, que axila é uma área que tem
muito folículo piloso, é uma área também
que fica
pouco eh circulação de ar, né? Também
pode fumar nas virilhas e nas nádengas.
É bem região de dobra, né, que dá mais
isso daí, dobras
cutâneas.
Tratamento é compressa quente para
estimular a drenagem do pus. Casos mais
graves tem que drenar com bisturi, né?
Tem que pronto socorro, mas dói bastante
essa drenagem com bisturi e uso de
antibióticos oral e às vezes caso mais
grave até
endovenoso. Você pode usar uns remédios
naturais da medicina integrativa, o caso
de plásticos de abóbora cozida. Você
pode cozinhar a abóbora e aplicar na
pele. Isso vai ajudar a amolecer a pele
e a espelir o pus. Também tem as
compressas de cebola crua, tem uma ação
antibacteriana, anti-inflamatória. O
óleo de melaleuco tem ação
antimicrobiana, né, antifúng e
antibacteriana. Você pode dierir o óleo
de melaleuca em óleo carreador, que pode
ser óleo de coco, pode ser óleo de
amênda, pode ser óleo de rícino, tem
vários óleos aí que você pode utilizar,
óleo de uva também e aplicar localmente
com
cotonete e fazer uso aí de nutrientes
antioxidantes, vitamina C, vitamina E,
os tocotrenóis, né? Zinco também, se
tiver deficiência de zinco para ajudar
na
imunidade e cortar os alimentos
inflamatórios.
Muitas pessoas que tem eh furucção é
porque estão com resistência à insulina,
pré-diabetes ou desequilíbrios imunes.
Então tem que investigar isso em
consultório com consulta e
exames. E preventivamente você pode
utilizar uma higiene rigorosa com
sabonete neutro, evitar compartilhar
objetos outras pessoas, objetos
pessoais, manter a pele seca e se o
furâncar em duas semanas e se ele também
piorar ou ter febre, é muito provável
que você vai precisar ir ao pronto
socorro para drenar a secreção de pulso,
né? Ele vai ter que passar um misturi
lá.
Temos aqui a participação da Eliane. Boa
noite, Eliane. Do Fernando Castelani ou
Castani. Agradecendo. Eu que agradeço
aqui, viu,
Fernando? Deixa eu ver se chegou mais
[Música]
pergunta. Não, não chegou não. E vocês
podem fazer as perguntas ao vivo, tá
pessoal?
Bem, deixa eu parar de compr de
compartilhar. Vamos achar aqui um artigo
para discutir hoje.
Tô procurando algum artigo aqui pra
gente
ver uma coisa que seja interesse de
vocês.
Tem um activo aqui que eu não sei se
eu dividir com
vocês, que é um que
compara uso de proteína vegetal com
proteína animal para crescimento
muscular.
Segundo esse artigo, as proteínas de
planta foram tão efetivas para melhorar
a força muscular do que as de origem
animal. Inclusive, tiveram mesmos
resultados de força e de performance
atlética. Eles fazem aqui só uma
ressalva que as proteínas animais foram
discretamente mais efetivas para
construir massa muscular.
mas que não foi significativa essa
vantagem. E essa vantagem só foi achado
em estudos em
adultos abaixo de 60 anos de
idade. E esses estudos também não
incluíram a proteína da soja.
Então, foi considerado que essa vantagem
é muito leve e não
significativa. E foi um estudo
randomizado,
metanálise. Eles juntaram só 32 estudos,
bastante coisa, todos eles controlados e
randomizados.
Então, praticamente não tem diferença,
só tem essa
leve vantagem da proteína animal para
construção de massa muscular em adultos
abaixo de 60 anos de
idade, mas não houve diferença na força
e não houve diferença na performance
atlética.
Deixa eu ver se eu acho mais alguma
conta do artigo interessante
aqui. Tem um aqui que tá falando sobre
tomar chá verde pode reduzir o risco de
défic
cognitivo. Então esse estudo
mostrou que foi análise de 11 estudos de
corte.
e sete
estudos
eh cross sectional, né, que chama em
inglês. Eu não sei como é que fala isso
em
português. Acho que isos transversais em
português. Comparado a nunca tomar ou
tomar raramente o chá verde, o consumo
maior de chá verde foi associado com
37% menos risco de teste cognitivo de
qualquer
tipo. e tem uma limitação nesse estudo,
porque a maioria
dos estudos foi com população
asiática, então eles podem querer dizer
que não tem o mesmo efeito na população
qual ca
qualca, caramba, como é que chama?
Calca, os brancos, né? Calcooide,
esqueci o nome agora que é.
Se alguém lembrar o nome da palavra, me
coloca aqui na no chat, por favor. É
calcasoide, não lembro agora o nome da
palavra. Então, vale a pena tomar chá
verde, previne déficit cognitivo. Essa
que é a conclusão aqui, apesar de ter
sido população mais asiática.
Um outro artigo interessante que
analisou é uma metaanálise de 61 estudos
clínicos com 3440 participantes para
saber se meditação ajuda no estresse
pós-traumático e o pessoal fazer de tr a
7 dias por semana por 10 a 45 minutos
curso de
sessão e fizeram uma duração variável de
1 a 48
semanas. E as técnicas utilizadas foram
meditação
transcendental,
mindfulness e também técnicas de mantra.
E aí toda a sala de meditação reduziu o
estresse prostraumático, só que a
meditação transcendental teve mais
efeito, enquanto que as outras formas de
meditação tiveram efeito
moderado. Interessante, né? né? Estudos
aí dando suporte a meditação
transcendental para o estresse
pós-traumático. Outro estudo
interessante
aqui, será que o uso de probióticos
ajuda no pré-diabetes?
Nesse estudo que foi uma metaálise de
oito estudos randomizados
controlados, um total de 585
participantes, os probióticos não
tiveram efeito
significativo na saúde
cardiometabólica. Eu acho que é razoável
isso. Os probióticos, de modo geral,
eles têm uma potência limitada.
Os prebióticos são bem mais
interessantes, bem mais
importantes. Outro estudo de
probiótico. Será que o uso probiótico na
população com
esquizofrenia pode ajudar a reduzir?
Eles utilizaram aí, né, nesses quatro
estudos randomizados que
foram agregados nessa
metaálise, o lactobacíos acidófilos, o
bífido bactérium bífidum e uma outra
bactéria chamada limiso lactobacilos que
é o lactobacutico, eles mudaram o nome,
né? E o lactobacíos
laminosos, eles tomaram de 8 a 10
bilhões de UFC, né? unidades formadoras
de colônia por 12 a 14 semanas.
E o resultado foi
que houve uma
redução moderada nos níveis da proteína
C reativa, que é o marcador
inflamatório, mas os resultados variaram
muito amplamente entre os estudos, então
não houve assim um resultado definitivo.
Então o estudo ficou confuso, né? Porque
foi muito dispare os resultados dos
quatro estudos que foram
juntos e aí eles não conseguiram chegar
a uma
conclusão, mas houve sim uma redução na
proteína ser
reativa, sem ter essa certeza que
ajudou.
na
esquizofrenia. Pessoal, vocês estão aí?
Não, todo mundo já foi dormir. Tô
falando sozinho aqui. Dei um alô aí. Tô
muito chato aqui hoje. Não, vocês estão
dormindo. Ah, tem um outro estudo
interessante aqui perguntando se a a
dieta vegana pode deixar adultos mais
velhos com risco maior de tacopenia. É
bem interessante
esse essa pergunta. Então,
foi um estudo de 10
dias com 34 adultos mais velhos.
Deixa eu ver qual que foi a conclusão
aqui. Bem, a conclusão é que se você
fizer uma dieta vegana bem
formulada, com grande variedade de
fontes diferentes de proteína vegetal,
que isso não aumentaria o risco de
sarcopenia em adultos mais velhos
comparados com uma dieta onívora,
comendo também proteína animal. Então é
possível sim você não ficar em
sarcopenia usando
dieta vegana, mas o cuidado é muito
grande. Tem que ter um cuidado bem
grande na hora de escolher as fontes de
proteína, porque a maioria do pessoal
que faz dieta
vegana faz uma dieta muito monótona e aí
acaba não se enquadrando aqui nesses
critérios e acaba entrando em sacopenia.
Então tem que tomar muito cuidado se a
pessoa optar por uma dieta vegana.
Obrigada. Alice aí para ter dado o valor
aqui, porque tava todo mundo calado
aqui, eu não sabia se tava falando
sozinho. Boa noite, o Zé
Eduardo perguntou Eliseu aqui, qual
suplemento seria indicado paraa dor no
membro fantasma. Não conheço um
suplemento que seria eficaz para isso,
tá?
Talvez o ácido
alfalipóico, gaba, comiteanina e taurina
ajudaria, mas eu acho que uma pessoa com
uma dor fantasma muito significativa ia
precisar usar gapentina ou pregabalina,
viu Eliseu? Bem difícil evitar isso daí.
Talvez
um um extrato de cannabis e ajudar
também, né? Um full
espectro, tá? Então não é tão
específico, tá? Eliseu, o fal porco é
bom para
neuropatia. El taurina é bom para
neuropatia. Nak pode ajudar, Tocotrenois
pode
ajudar, mas eu acho que é precisar
complementar com gabapentina ou
pregabalina e talvez um
flucto. Eh, certralina não é
antibiótico, tá, Eliseu? Ctrralina é um
antidepressivo. Qual suplemento poderia
substituir a
certralina? 5 HTP poderia, em alguns
casos, substituir junto
com o uso
da erva de São João, tá? Que tem um
efeito
antidepressivo. Atrexona poderia
substituir, o lítium
orotato poderia
substituir, tá? O azul de metileno
também tem efeito
antidepressivo, mas tem que ser visto
caso a caso, tá? Não é tão simples
assim. Quem mais, pessoal?
Então eu vou encerrar com para 10,
paraas 8, eu vou encerrar, tá bom? a
live.
Temos 3 minutos ainda.
Recentemente alguém fez uma pesquisa e
concluiu que as cinco zonas azuis são
mentira e é tudo uma faça. Quem é que
fez essa
pesquisa? Tem que falar a fonte, Eliseu.
Eu não acho que seja faça não. Minha
opinião que não é fácil coisa nenhuma.
Os números são discutíveis que as
pessoas vivem mais nessas regiões, tá? É
só você em
Okinaua. E eu conheço o Rafael Escapela
que visitou a capela lá de Oknaua e ele
comprovou pessoalmente que as pessoas
vivem há mais de 100 anos lá, tá? Então
não é uma farça não, tá?
Eh, as outras regiões do Globo é
Lomalinda, aquela região da Costa
Rica, aquela região da Grécia, lá,
Icária. Eu não tenho uma tantos detalhes
dessas regiões, mas eu não tenho razão
de achar que isso é uma face.
[Música]
Bem, pessoal, eu acho que é isso por
hoje. Nós nos vemos na semana que
vem, OK? E deem sugestões se vocês
quiserem que a gente mude esse formato
da live semanal, tá bom? Abraço, um
beijo no coração de vocês.